You skipped past this.
A beat.
Oh,
Jeremy Stephens.
Yeah.
Which I thought crazy.
Crazy and no,
I mean for as a beat to beat the number six here in the world.
Yeah,
it was good.
Good,
fine.
What'd you think?
Um,
I didn't think it helps a beet stock because there's so much hype on him.
You didn't think you look hungry.
I really,
well,
first of all,
he's fighting Jeremy.
Steve Agree.
Jeremy Stevens is fucking dangerous.
You can't pass any mistakes with that guy.
Zero.
You're getting locked out.
You look good.
I thought,
I thought I looked okay.
I didn't think it stock went through the roof with that fight.
You didn't walk away from that fight going,
oh my God,
I can't wait to see him fight again.
What?
That will look good.
But when you,
when you hear Mark Henry's coach talk about them.
I mean they talk about him like he's the next fucking,
did you see that three 60 roundhouse kick?
He tried.
Yeah.
That missed
this shit so fast.
He's really fast and his,
his round kick to the body is just so fast.
Like lightning.
Amazing.
Throw such a tech.
Such a talent.
Yeah.
So technical to everything he does is very smooth.
Doesn't get head,
doesn't play that game.
No,
no.
It doesn't play the game that Cody Garbrandt played with Pedro.
Cody fight was crazy.
I just losses in a row.
Three,
nine,
three Kaos in a row.
I just couldn't believe he was standing with him like that.
He got them hurt and then he got hurt and then he was determined to take him out
and then they were literally going right hand,
right hand or right hand till someone fell.
Yeah.
And Pedro can take a shot.
So can Cody.
Yeah.
I hate shots.
He ate some big ones,
but it makes no sense if you're Cody.
So technical.
I know it doesn't make any sense the head,
but he said he got head button than just saw Rett.
But he definitely did.
He definitely got headbutted.
Aaron Peko Ish.
And he talked about it.
He said he saw red,
like got angry after that had bought it.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
You got to fight and tell it.
I mean,
obviously it's super easy for us to say,
you know,
sitting here drinking coffee.
Yeah,
don't fight it.
Don't fight her angry bro.
You know,
it's easy to say,
but that's also what makes him so dynamic.
Agree.
It's what got them to the party.
But as a former fighter,
it's like coming off two losses,
which I've been there.
You're usually a little more like,
I'm not going to go down that road.
I've been knocked out twice.
I know how that ends.
If I get hit,
let's learn from our mistakes.
That's what's the troubling part.
Yeah.
And He,
uh,
he has a speed advantage.
Patrell monies.
I was very good timing,
but I think Colby has a speed advantage technique and speed on the feet on the
ground.
It's all Pedro on the feed out here all day.
I mean,
Cody Garbrandt still only 27 years old and still could be world champion again.
No,
no doubt about it.
Well,
three losses.
Pedro Munoz.
Okay.
You played that game laws.
But then the other two are Tj Dillashaw.
Okay.
Still the champ as your number.
Who gives a fuck.
And in both of those fights he hurt Tj Dillashaw.
He's just gotta be more cautious and fight more technical.
More disciplined.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
wouldn't be a bad idea to get some mental coaching,
you know,
get some game plan coaching,
which he might've doing.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'm just speculating.
I don't know who he's training his striking with either.
But you know,
to mix things up more and be more unpredictable would also be a good thing.
I mean,
obviously the,
the last exchanges,
we're just not predictable at all or I mean not unpredictable at all.
Fully predictable.
Just right hand,
right hand,
right hand.
Just chaos.
You know,
what is his last one?
He beat Dominick Cruz,
which is,
you've got to be cerebral in that fight to be done.
The cruise.
Yeah,
he had Dom's number.
I mean it was a different kind of fun.
It's interesting.
Dom said that he did the exact thing that Cody did in their fight,
that he got hit and he got emotional and he fought reckless dom and Tom went
after Cody.
That interesting.
Yeah.
He said,
I know what it's like.
You just,
you lose your game plan.
You start,
you get wild.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's hard to see him get Kayo three times in a row like fat.
He's going to be fine.
I hope so.
He's going to be fun.
He'll learn from it.
But here's the thing,
when you're ranked,
was he number two in that division?
It's not like,
all right,
let's give you a warm up fight.
Boxing.
There's no warmups.
Right?
He's going to get Jimmy Rivera or fucking stir aljamain.
Hell,
Jermaine.